[Música]
en sambo que tiene lugar la obra del
siglo hacer renacer 6 hectáreas y media
de jardines a la francesa hoy en día
desaparecidos para realizar esta proeza
habrán sido necesarios no menos de 15
años de investigaciones y meses de obras
la explanada de sant boi irreconocible
doce mil metros cúbicos de tierra han
sido transportados desplazados y
nivelados bajo el ojo atento del
ingeniero jefe
la tierra es buena
hay muchos desechos en ella
la tierra es buena si encontramos
piedras las ponemos a un lado los
pacifistas somos al principio que un
chambord era recuperar la tierra que
existía fue mezclada y trabajada y
almacenar in situ y aunque han actuado
detergente efe no hay ningún aporte de
tierra para evitar las idas y venidas de
camiones
una vez que la tierra ha sido depositada
hay que sembrar más de 600 árboles en
total cerezos y tilos para los
jardineros el momento es delicado hay
que ser aplicado todo debe ser perfecto
espera hay que rascar de ese lado
estamos golpeando la por acá dura
cuando se les ve trabajar es muy preciso
si al centímetro hay que ubicar los
terrones con respecto al nivel del suelo
la tierra debe estar al nivel del cuello
y más alto ni más bajo la altura
necesaria
los productos que hizo
y vamos en 10
los árboles son ajustados a ojo vamos
hacia mí
es mucho más suelta suelta es mucho un
poco menos
la siembra de árboles ha terminado una
mezcla de piedra caliza y grava es
entregada para los senderos del jardín
en el siglo 17 se necesitaban años para
hacer estas excavaciones hoy en día son
necesarios tan sólo tres meses para
terminar estos senderos
empleamos máquinas que están reservadas
para obras en carreteras y vías urbanas
la zona es gigantesca estamos hablando
de seis hectáreas y media
muy cerca de los caminos en construcción
un topógrafo y un albañil esbozan los
contornos de uno de las cuatro flores de
lis gigantes
entonces tomó medidas y gracias a ellas
se la posición para los cortes de las
flores y así sucesivamente
luego me da un punto y mohamed solo debe
sembrar su tallo y así tenemos la
posición exacta de las flores
en el suelo las estacas esbozan el
dibujo
suelta en bandas metálicas a lo largo de
las varillas la flor toma forma
cada flor de lis cubrirá tres mil metros
cuadrados media cancha de fútbol
lo clave para los jardineros es
delimitar perfectamente el sendero y
césped
el trazado no sufre ninguna aproximación
tratamos sobre todo de no poner tierra
sobre la piedra caliza hay pequeños
errores como éste pasamos con un
soplador para las malas hierbas que no
crezcan y los sondeos
mientras tanto en una de las torres del
castillo el ingeniero jefe de la obra
recibe la visita del conservador general
del patrimonio
tienes el detalle de los arbustos o no
o de los arbustos las flores y los tejos
los dos hombres se examinan un archivo
excepcional de
1749 senderos por rastrillar en arena el
contrato de mantenimiento del jardín a
la francesa de aquella época todo queda
referenciado es una fuente preciosa de
información
entonces el jardinero nunca debe podar
sin una orden les ha sido los archivos
son tan precisos todos los documentos
son tan precisos que no podemos inventar
no es una reinvención es una restitución
idéntica esperamos que gracias a las
obras podemos aparecer el fantasma de
este jardín
tras una siembra invernal exitosa la
propiedad de sant boi ofrece siete meses
más tarde su mejor cara
esta era la vista que louis 15 tenía
cuando observaba sus jardines en
1734 senderos ligeros simétricos una
armonía perfecta que los visitantes
aprecian
es una reconstitución de un jardín a la
francesa muy bella un trabajo muy bello
había visto en televisión que había sido
renovado y todo un éxito
para el director de la propiedad este
jardín revela nuevas sorpresas cada día
a mí me gusta mucho este lugar porque
empezamos a tener algunos colores con
los bordes de tomillo las flores las
plantas perennes que salen y también
esta vista el coso no el estanque el
resultado está a la altura del costo del
proyecto
[Música]
tres millones y medio de euros
el castillo está engarzado en un jardín
elegante que florecerá durante los
próximos años